Godfrey yes I was describing you to
somebody uh somebody else you know I
mean they go who is that I go I
subscribe and I said that he has big
teeth would that be no I don't that's
yeah yeah I know you don't have your
teeth his white teeth no but I said big
teeth and he goes yeah yeah and then I
showed a photo and he's like no
definitely the guy doesn't have big
teeth you know Big T I would have been
like yeah you right
but I don't yeah I have like all right
your average no I didn't get them now
they're very nice that's just the
projection because you're missing teeth
are you missing teeth oh yeah let me see
no no I have a good afterwards I have
crowns no no I'm missing half teeth half
teeth if I open my mind you have to have
teeth I got there are half of them are
gone no you you
you're only seeing the show business
ones oh the ones yeah
no no it's like I swear people with full
teeth only brush the ones that they
smile with they just go that's how cool
the ones in the back well that's how
Crest White Strips work I always wonder
why they only have just a strip really
for the front yeah that's no you got to
get the ones that are working hard in
the back yeah just the quarterback but
my parents never taught me what you
never taught me how to brush my parents
were so adamant about brushing teeth and
washing and that they were like hygiene
was like like when we woke up in the
morning and you know we're Nigerians so
my father would be like you know as soon
as we get up you say you say good
morning fast then
that's my father said you say good
morning fast yeah and then you go to the
to the rest and and wash your mouth wash
them wash your brush your teeth before
you come out you'll just be smelly yeah
you can't have that yeah say good
morning to your mother and then you go
and watch oh yeah that was a rule in our
household too like the first thing you
had to I had to say was good morning
Papa a very formal way too that was good
morning Daddy good morning Mommy you
know what that Nigerian accent I love it
when there are scientists in movies I
can't do it the reactors
and you know what because Nigerians are
scientists yeah that's what it is
they're usually really internet yeah if
you ask anything the engineers lawyers
right right I think mathematical and I
played by the way this is really great
because I played a Nigerian student in a
science lab with Keanu Reeves and Morgan
Freeman's called chain reaction
I just did a couple lines hello Mr
professor
because the guy Andy Davis the director
he really liked me and I was like he and
I didn't act like I did an accent and he
was like I love that I want you to so I
played a sign so I'm with Keanu Reeves
for a few weeks yeah and Morgan Freeman
I'm like this is great he's like yo
that's a good accent yeah wait wait let
me ask you something between the two
right were they both nice very they seem
like nice guys let me tell you something
okay I met you you run it you're like
Keanu Reeves I'm like oh [__] it's Keanu
Reeves like damn yeah every day I'm
seeing him and one day he's like we're
all going to lunch right I'm just
walking with him like I'm walking
[__] kill reach it's cool and
then and then these girls saw him oh my
God and when I tell you like they were
like oh my God and he was just nice the
nicest thing he did he signed
everybody's autograph shook everybody's
hand I said I was respect you for that
[__] now I like the guy he's very nice
very nice guy he's a little strange
sometimes but that's all right we're you
know it's what we do you would think
that if you're walking with Keanu Reeves
you'd always have a raincoat because
when you run into women [__] juice yeah
yeah I mean you would think yeah they
were screaming for me too you know and I
was scared
I was scared I was the the Ricochet
[__] you know
so I remember I remember good bad name
Ricochet [__] juice yeah yeah yeah
that's our first song
Hey Berlin Ricochet
Ricochet [__] juice
when it bounces off it goes in the
bucket and I say [__] it with the same
[__] juice yeah that's correct sell out
all over Germany
like this dude did you see Ricochet
[__] juice those guys are so good they
just opened up for pubic hair weird it's
a Nigerian and a Korean yeah it's a
Nigerian Korean it's a great combination
I've never seen yeah that paint city was
on the [__] bill too dude yeah it was
awesome there really is a thing though
when like a band is only a hit in like
one specific place that's amazing like
Ricky Gervais
um he was a synth pop um part of a sin
pop Duo that was only big in the
Philippines you know that right it's the
weirdest [__] you know that no yeah he
was he look at what this is Ricky what's
that Ricky Gervais